der g-20-gipfel der industriestaaten
virtuell und beherrscht von einer frage
wie kann die welt die korona krise
überwinden
ein neues grundsatzprogramm und ein
klares ziel grünen-chef harbeck sieht
seine partei auf dem weg ins kanzleramt
und klimaforscher im weltraum der
radarsatellit sentinel 6 soll den
anstieg des meeresspiegels im blick
halten präzise wie nie zuvor
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert könig für den sport
genommen
wir beginnen mit einer video schalte der
mächtigsten staats und regierungschefs
den g20 gipfel ein spannendes treffen
längst nicht nur weil us-präsident am
nun doch überraschend teilnimmt die g20
das ist die gruppe der großen
wirtschaftsmächte also der europäischen
union und 19 ländern hier leben zwei
drittel aller menschen weltweit
beim gipfel geht es zwei tage um zwei
große herausforderungen
die korona pandemie und die klimakrise
und dann ist da noch ein brisantes thema
abseits der tagesordnung menschenrechte
im gastgeberland saudi arabien anne
gellinek ein einsamer reiter trägt die
fahne des g 20 klubs durch die saudische
wüste kampfflugzeuge steigen über riad
in die luft saudi arabien wäre gern
stolzer gastgeber des g 20 klubs gewesen
wegen der korona krise aber ist der
gipfel zu einer video-konferenz
geschrumpft europäischen teilnehmern
bleibt damit die heikle begegnung mit
dem saudischen könig und dem kronprinzen
erspart die wegen zahlreicher
menschenrechtsverletzungen in der kritik
stehen in der eröffnungsrede ruft er
fast 85 jährige könig sei man dazu auf
die pandemie und ihre folgen gemeinsam
zu bekämpfen
unsere bürger und volkswirtschaften
stehen noch immer unter schock
wir werden unser bestes tun die krise
durch internationale zusammenarbeit zu
bewältigen
donald trump hatte die g 20 treffen der
letzten jahre lahmgelegt der inzwischen
abgewählte us präsident nimmt zwar am
nachmittag teil beschwert sich aber
parallel per twitter über angeblichen
wahlbetrug im us staat georgia die
europäer haben längst seinem nachfolger
joe biden gratuliert und freuen sich
unverhohlen auf einen neustart der
zusammenarbeit im kampf gegen korona der
united states die vereinigten staaten
haben sich bei diesem thema bislang
verweigert aber ich hoffe dass das unter
dem neu gewählten präsidenten
das los angeles unterdessen treu und
verspricht zuerst alle amerikaner zu
impfen
saudis chinesen und europäer werben
dagegen für mehr geld für eine
internationale initiative die dafür
sorgen soll dass auch ärmere länder
zugang zu impfstoffen bekommen
während donald trump die letzten
g20-gipfel durch blockade beherrschte
ist er jetzt nur noch eine randnotiz
die europäer hoffen dass die neue
us-regierung als vollwertiges mitglied
in den g20 klub zurückkehrt und mitmacht
beim kampf gegen korona und den
klimawandel zu den crooner zahlen die
halten sich in deutschland weiter auf
hohem niveau
laut robert koch institut gab es binnen
24 stunden 22 1964 neuinfektionen im
vergleich zum samstag der vergangenen
woche sind das 503 mehr
die zahl der todesfälle im zusammenhang
mit dem virus stieg um 254 und jetzt
nach leipzig wo vor zwei wochen eine
sogenannte querdenker querdenker demo
für ärger und dann zu politischen
debatten geführt hatte kaum einer der
20.000 demonstranten hat er sich an die
masken pflicht gehalten
auch heute versammelten sich wieder
gegner der korona maßnahmen in der stadt
gleichzeitig beteiligten sich auch viele
an gegenprotesten über den tag in
leipzig stefan kech die bürgerinitiative
leipzig nimmt platz will sich den
augustusplatz zurückerobern
das symbol für den friedlichen protest
von 1989
der war vor zwei wochen von einer
großdemo gegen die korona maßnahmen mit
bezug auf 89 besetzt worden
für bürgerrechtlerinnen wie gesine
oltmanns ist das schwer erträglich es
hat ganz viele unheimlich betroffen
gemacht
und auch wütend dass dieser diese ringen
der für uns wirklich ein symbol dafür
ist für den aufbruch in demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit dass der so
gebraucht worden ist polizei und
ordnungskräfte sorgen diesmal konsequent
dafür dass die korona verordnung
eingehalten wird
null toleranz haben sie angekündigt das
muss auch der anmelder einer demo von
kritikern der groner maßnahmen erfahren
der will keine maske tragen aus
gesundheitlichen gründen kann ich keine
frage
doch dieses attest stellt sich als
unzureichend heraus die versammlung wird
beendet noch bevor sie angefangen hat
seine etwa 500 anhänger müssen den
versammlungsort verlassen
zur stunde sind viele teilnehmer der
verschiedensten versammlungen in der
stadt unterwegs vereinzelt berichtet die
polizei auch von zusammenstößen
der kampf gegen die pandemie in der
türkei ist für die regierung eine
besondere gratwanderung denn obwohl die
angeschlagenen ihrer sicht zuletzt
einigermaßen erholt hat bleibt die
wirtschaftslage angespannt die zweite
infektionswelle zwingt das land trotzdem
zu maßnahmen
seit gestern sind die restaurants und
cafés wieder dicht und es gilt erneut
eine ausgangssperre von abends acht bis
morgens um 10
die straßen sind leer ausgangssperre im
ganzen land doch erstmal nur für samstag
nacht
bis gestern abend durften restaurants
noch öffnen auch damit so hatte es der
präsident verkündet ist ab diesem
wochenende schluss die restaurants und
cafés werden essen nur noch ausliefern
alle sportwettkämpfe werden ohne
zuschauer ausgetragen
die teehäuser werden bis auf weiteres
geschlossen seit wochen schon dürfen
ältere und junge nur stundenweise auf
die straße im freien darf nicht mehr
geraucht werden
es gilt ein regel wird über dass sich
einige in den sozialen netzwerken lustig
machen viele andere aber sind
verunsichert
die neuen maßnahmen reichen nicht aus
sie sehen doch wie voll es hier ist das
wird nicht reichen
ich glaube nicht an die veröffentlichten
zahlen
ich denke wir bräuchten einen kompletten
shutdown für mindestens drei wochen
die regierung verspricht dass ein
impfstoff schon bald zur verfügung stehe
gesundheitsexperten warnen dass die zeit
drängt wenn wir in zwei wochen noch
immer dort stehen wo wir jetzt mit den
maßnahmen angefangen haben und wenn die
zahl der schwerkranken weiter zunimmt
und wir an die grenzen des
gesundheitssystems stoßen dann müssen
härteren maßnahmen getroffen werden
vorerst aber bleibt die regierung bei
den nur nächtlichen ausgangssperren aus
angst vor größerem schaden für die
türkische wirtschaft
und wie die korona lage in deutschlands
nachbarländern ist sehen sie in unserer
zdf heute app ein interaktiver überblick
zur infektionszahlen aktuellen maßnahmen
und vielem mehr
corona zwingt auch die grünen dazu ihren
parteitag virtuell abzuhalten in
umfragen liegen sie aktuell bei 20
prozent und streben entsprechend
selbstbewusst ins kanzleramt
jetzt brauchen sie noch ein neues
grundsatzprogramm dass möglichst viele
mitnimmt und wenige verprellt aus berlin
andreas ruppert und las bohnsack alles
ist anders dieses mal tägliche corona
schnelltests für vorstand mitarbeiter
und presse die delegierten aber sind nur
online dabei nicht alles funktioniert
reibungslos
leider hören wir dich noch nicht
jetzt ist wieder das problem philipp wir
sehen dich zwar aber wir hören dich
nicht erhört heiter digital die grünen
geben sich ein neues grundsatzprogramm
und formulieren dabei ganz klar ihren
machtanspruch sie wollen ins kanzleramt
aber wenn es stimmt dass eine neue zeit
neue antworten erfordert das eine neue
zeit einen neuen ton eine farbe der
hoffnung braucht dann stellen wir uns
diesem anspruch sagt der weg zur macht
der fordert kompromisse auch solche die
ganz grundsätzliche der partei gehen und
die nicht jeder mittragen will
beispiel klimaschutz die letzten monate
waren hart und trotzdem es mir für paris
weiterhin kämpfen
vielleicht ist jetzt gerade oder heute
genau der zeitpunkt wo ihr euch
vielleicht einmal fragen können warum
wir mal mit uns auf den straßen
gestanden hat ich bin mental können wir
uns nicht mehr leisten dazu ist es zu
spät
erst auf druck von basis und
umweltaktivisten werden die klimaziele
verschärft gemeinsam unseren text
nochmal besser und deutlicher gemacht
auch mit der perspektive das jetzt in
den nächsten zehn jahren was passieren
muss und deswegen geht von dieser stelle
jetzt eine neue zusätzliche kraft aus
die grünen wollen regieren auch im bund
dieses selbstbewusstsein zeigt sich auch
im neuen grundsatzprogramm ralf
schumacher in berlin
in welchem dilemma stecken die grünen ja
der machtanspruch der parteispitze sorgt
an der basis für bauchschmerzen neue
wählerschichten sollen gewonnen werden
der weg ins kanzleramt erfordert
kompromisse und die abkehr von alten
forderungen das neue grundsatzprogramm
markiert den schritt von der öko zur
grünen volkspartei
andererseits ist da der enorme zulauf
von klimaaktivisten die entschlossenheit
fordern im kampf gegen die erderwärmung
eine klar hier in berlin wurde gerade so
umschifft aber es bleibt ein schwieriger
spagat für die grünen
und es droht konkurrenz im öko lager
vieler orts sprießen kleine parteien aus
dem boden vernetzt in der neuen klima
liste deutschland die spd hat ihren
kanzlerkandidaten die union ringt um den
iren aber die grünen wollen der partie
noch nicht drüber reden oder die aus
sicht der partei ist das eher ein
luxusproblem das duo baerbock habeck
funktioniert wird gemeinsam für die
grüne sache statt sich im
konkurrenzkampf zu verschleißen
noch jedenfalls aber natürlich wächst
der druck der führungsanspruch betont
ohne zu sagen wer führt der gerät
irgendwann in erklärungsnot geht es nach
den grünen soll die entscheidung erst
rund um ostern fallen
informationen von grünen-parteitag
dankeschön ralf schumacher nach den
störaktionen von gästen der afg fraktion
im bundestag hält thüringens
innenminister georg meyer spd ein verbot
der afg für denkbar wenn eine partei
sich immer weiter radikalisiere stehe am
ende die möglichkeit eines parteien
verbots sagte meier gegenüber dem zdf
die afg versuche die demokratie von
innen heraus anzugreifen
thüringens heute wieder gewählte afg
chef ziercke nannte meyer äußerung so
wörtlich dämlich
eine verbindliche frauenquote für
vorstände großer unternehmen darauf
hatte sich die große koalition gestern
geeinigt der präsident des deutschen
instituts für wirtschaftsforschung sieht
darin eine hohe signalwirkung für
gleichstellung und chancengleichheit
politikerinnen von grünen und linken
kritisierten der schritt sei zu klein im
afghanischen kabul sind bei einem
anschlag mindestens acht menschen
getötet worden mehr als 30 wurden
verletzt zahlreiche mörsergranaten
schlugen in wohngebieten ein
auch im botschaftsviertel gab es
explosionen
trotz friedensgesprächen zwischen
regierung und radikal islamischen
taliban gibt es immer wieder anschläge
in afghanistan
einige reklamierte terror miliz
islamischer staat für sich
in brasilien haben in mehreren städten
hunderte gegen rassismus demonstriert
nach dem gewaltsamen tod eines schwarzen
sie trugen transparente mit der
aufschrift schwarze leben zählen
am donnerstagabend hatten
sicherheitskräfte eines supermarkts den
40 jährigen zu tode geprügelt filialen
der supermarktkette wurden von
demonstrierenden gestürmt und verwüstet
vor allem für küstenbewohner ist es eine
bedrohung der stetig steigende
meeresspiegel vor einer stunde startete
ein satellit der diese entwicklung
besser im blick hat denn je sentinel
sechs hier in originalgröße ist ein
hochmoderner satellit des europäischen
erdbeobachtungsprogramm sogar nikos mit
an bord ein extrem leistungsstarkes
radar
es kann aus einer höhe von etwa 1300
kilometer
die meeresoberfläche vermessen und so
früher vor überflutungen warnen trinken
klinge
pünktlich um 18 uhr 17 ist in
kalifornien erstmals eine space extrakte
mit einem esa satelliten an bord
gestartet sentinel 6 soll mit einem
neuen radardaten liefern mit denen die
höhe des meeres millimeter genau
bestimmt werden
kann der satellit sendet radar impulse
aus und fängt sie reflektiert vom wasser
wieder auf das nicht einmal macht
sondern wir einen sehr langen zeitraum
denn wo dann sieht man diese effekte
seit knapp 30 jahren liefern satelliten
bereits daten über den ozean
in dieser zeit ist der meeresspiegel um
etwa neun zentimeter angestiegen
sentinel 6 wird zunächst mit seinem
vorgänger jason drei als tandem
unterwegs sein bis er ihn vollständig
ablöst die daten über den anstieg der
meere werden dann hier bearbeitet bei
mit sat in darmstadt zuständig für
meteorologische satelliten in europa
dieser anstieg scheint sich zu
beschleunigen
das wäre mit central sechs nachweisen
können
und dieser anstieg ist eine
temperaturerhöhung ist auch mehr wasser
in den ozean also gesamte wasserhaushalt
spiegelt sich da wieder die mission
sentinel 6 ist ein gemeinschaftliches
projekt von esa und nasa verschiedene
berechnungen gehen von einem anstieg des
meeresspiegels von rund einem meter bis
zum ende des jahrhunderts aus im sport
wird auch geflogen norbert die
skispringer sind wieder los mit einem
platz auf dem treppchen für das deutsche
quartett die form stimmt schon bei
weltmeister markus eisenbichler und
seinen kollegen im mannschaftswettbewerb
von reese war in polen müssen sie sich
zum weltcup-auftakt nur dem team aus
österreich geschlagen geben
ein kleiner gleichgewichts fehler
kostete den sieg markus eisenbichler
sicherte mit dieser risikoreichen
landung bei 127 meter aber platz zwei
für das deutsche team mit constantin
schmid pius paschke und kalk am ende was
sehr knapp
das ist eine ganz fehlerfrei geblieben
leider aber für den ersten wettkampf
sehr gut eine knappe niederlage gegen
österreich schlussspringer stefan kraft
mit einem technisch sauberen sprung auf
127 meter beeindruckte nicht nur die
drittplatzierten polen der erste
saisonsieg vor deutschland das aber mit
markus eisenbichler morgen im einzel
auch ein sieganwärter hat maria man
janka und francesco friedrich haben ihre
zweierbobs zum sieg gesteuert beim
weltcup-auftakt in sigulda in lettland
der elfmalige weltmeister friedrich
verdrängt mit seinem anschieber torsten
marx durch einen start im zweiten lauf
seine teamkollegen johannes lochner noch
auf platz zwei olympiasieger janka fuhr
mit ihrer neuen anschieberin vanessa
mark bei deren weltcup-debüt zum sieg 13
hundertstel vor dem team österreich
kleiner rückschlag für hansi flick in
seinem 50
pflichtspiel als cheftrainer von bayern
münchen es reicht nur zum unentschieden
in der bundesliga partie gegen werder
bremen
kingsley kommen verhindert immerhin mit
seinem treffer zum 1 1 die erste
heimniederlage seit einem jahr
leverkusen bleibt ungeschlagen gewinnt 2
zu 1 in bielefeld mönchengladbach und
augsburg trennen sich eins zu eins
hoffenheim geschafft trotz des ausfalls
von elf mann ein 3 3 gegen stuttgart
über die korona probleme der tsg erzählt
sportchef rosen im aktuellen sportstudio
schalke weiter sieglos 0 2 gegen
wolfsburg am abend noch frankfurt gegen
leipzig und härter dortmund zwei spiele
morgen die bayern nur noch einen zähler
vor leverkusen leipzig und dortmund
können noch punkten
aufsteiger stuttgart und werder noch in
der ersten tabellenhälfte unten warten
noch fünf mannschaften auf ihr resultat
vom achten spieltag schalke bleibt
vorletzter es sei denn mainz gewinnt
morgen in freiburg
das war vielen dank das fest der liebe
erzählen mit zwei abend spielen wie
gewohnt um 23 uhr
es war jetzt gemein entschuldigung und
morgen gibt es drei streifen wetter sagt
gunther tiersch heißt sonne an den
küsten trüb in der mitte und sonne im
süden mehr dazu gleich
um vl freut sich christian sievers auf
sie im heute journal und wir freuen uns
wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind
machen sie sich einen schönen
samstagabend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau am liebe zuschauer im norden wird
es jetzt noch nasser und für uns alle
wird es morgen etwas milder werden
die luft kommt aus westen und da ist es
eben milder und sie erreicht die ostsee
sie erreicht das baltikum da ist es
frostfrei erst wieder östlich von moskau
haben wir den dauerfrost und am
mildesten am wärmsten ist es immer noch
im mittelmeer derzeit 15 bis 20 grad zum
teil und bei uns ja da bleibt es
frostfrei im norden dafür wird es wieder
frostig im süden minus 1 bis minus 7
grad bei dem klaren himmel bilden sich
nebelfelder in norddeutschland
allerdings an den küsten da regnet wo
die ganze nacht über bei einem kräftigen
westwind dann kommt morgen nach dem
regen dort die sonne raus das wird ganz
freundlich immer noch ein starker wind
aus westen sonst aber noch regen im
norddeutschen tiefland der nachmittags
immer schwächer wird auch in der mitte
ist es eher trüb dann im süden
freundlicher da scheint erst einmal
meist die sonne
mit nebelfeldern vor allen dingen an der
donau und zum nachmittag hin werden die
wolken aus norden etwas dichter ist
bleibt dort aber trocken temperaturen
dann im nebel naja 2 grad im östlichen
bayern sonst aber etwas höher mit sieben
bis elf grad und die aussichten ja es
wird dann kaum noch regnen dienst auch
am mittwoch trockenes wetter teils
neblig-trüb teils auch sonnig ich
wünsche dir noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut